andré a acheté sa maison il ya vingt ans
dans l'acte de vente
une servitude de passage avec les clés
accordé à sa voisine celle ci pouvait
donc circuler sur une portion de son
terrain pour accéder à un stationnement
après quelques années sa voisine n'ayant
jamais utilisé son droit de passage
andré décident d'installer une piscine
qui empiète sur la servitude
tout va bien jusqu'au jour où andré
décide de vendre sa propre cloud
cette histoire de servitude fait fuir
les acheteurs potentiels
personne n'a envie de voir des voisins
passer sur son futur père andré se
renseigne
il découvre que le code civil prévoit
qu'une servitude parfait si elle n'est
pas utilisée pendant plus de dix ans
'l'annonce donc à sa voisine qu'elle a
perdu son droit de passage mais celle ci
ne le prend pas elles prétendent avoir
utilisé en contournant la piscine
à défaut de s'entendre avec sa voisine
andré deux rallyes devant le tribunal il
devra être très convaincants pour
démontrer au juge que la servitude a
pris feu la présence de ces piscines et
l'aménagement de son terrain devait
l'aider à démontrer que sa voisine n'a
pas utilisé son droit de passage depuis
plus de dix ans le fin mot de l'histoire
une servitude n'est pas éternelles il
s'en débarrasser peut être un casse tête